i don't care if we stay in contention
all the way down to the uh they have the
playoffs uh we've got to start
showing our fans more importantly
showing ourselves that we can do the
things to win the
games i love that jerry jones makes
himself so available to the media if i
was a cowboys fan i would hate it every
week it's something else every week it's
another effort to try to pull the court
on the lawnmower and get this team
turned around and nothing is working and
it wasn't working last night for the
cowboys beyond the first drive they had
the great first drive and then they had
some some good plays and some touchdowns
and points in garbage time in between it
was all bears it was three and out three
and out three and out over and over
again for the dallas cowboys and it's a
testament to the bears but it's also an
indictment of the cowboys coaching staff
their inability or their reluctance to
even try to make adjustments on the fly
they just think they go out and they run
their plays and they run their defense
and it's all very simple and we're good
enough to just go out there and win
through sheer force of physicality and
will and it just doesn't work and it's
not working whether it's a failure of
coaching whether the players aren't as
good as jerry jones thinks they are
whether they're very talented
individually but they don't come
together and play as a team like the
patriots would there's a problem with
the cowboys and yeah they're still in
first place in the nfc east by a half
game over the philadelphia eagles but at
some point they have to win again i
don't think the cowboys are gonna win
the division if they finish six and ten
although there is a way that that can
actually happen they're going to have to
win at some point and if they do end up
winning the division by default what the
hell are they going to do when the 49ers
of the seahawks show up in the wild card
round big cat well jerry can tell
everyone that they got to the playoffs
and jason garrett got into the playoffs
you bring up a good point
jerry jones trying to get you know rally
the troops every single game after every
single disappointing loss why doesn't he
try something different why does he not
talk to the media why doesn't he walk by
the media and say no comment i'm that
mad maybe that would help uh to your
other point mike in terms of the cowboys
and where they go from here and and what
the season looks like i'm gonna throw it
back to you and ask you this question if
the cowboys were in a division right now
with a team that had 10 wins and they
were already not eliminated from the
playoffs but maybe one game away do you
think that jason garrett would still be
the coach because this is such a weird
situation where a team is floundering
absolutely floundering and when i look
at teams late in december or you know
mid december late december it's all
about to me
the defensive intensity and if guys want
to tackle that means the team is still
bought in and still wants to win the
cowboys did not want to tackle last
night and you see it with some teams
where they just kind of say you know
what we're close to week 14 15 16. we're
just gonna kind of get our way to the
off season so you think
that the only reason jason garrett still
has a job is because the cowboys are
still somehow in first place even though
they've been so pathetic
if the eagles were as good this year as
they should have been if they hadn't
been racked by injuries at pretty much
every position except quarterback and
were running away with it i think
garrett would be gone and jerry jones
would pick the assistant coach that he
is most intrigued by as a potential
coaching candidate for next year and
just give the guy a chance to coach his
way into the job show me what you can do
chris richard or even kellen moore who
still looks like he walked out of 8th
grade
science class i mean give one of those
guys a chance because the reason garrett
is still on the job is because they're
still alive they still theoretically
have the chance to to get to the
playoffs and make noise there and you
know for for his
we still don't understand quite how the
bears have done it i mean it's easy
after the fact to go back and look at
what they did but but before it began
we didn't think it was ever going to
happen that's how we feel about the
cowboys now so you never know when it's
going to emerge will it be next week
against the rams will it be the next
week against the eagles it's got to be
one of those two weeks so they're not
going to the playoffs but but you know
jerry jones has allowed himself to have
as you said last week the fan mentality
that it's not over we're not out of it
and we're just going to hope that
something changes but when you look at
all the objective evidence there's no
reason to think anything will
yeah the you know what they actually
remind me of a little bit right now is
uh the 2017 atlanta falcons when they
kept on saying you know we haven't
played our best game yet and i made the
joke over and over well i'm still
waiting for their best game like i went
into 2018 wondering if the falcons had
played their best game in 2017 yet the
cowboys have that feel to them where the
talent is there and you look at the
roster and you scratch your head and say
when is this going to click and guess
what it may never click they might just
finish the season
losing out and still have be alive in
week 16 or week 17 and you're saying to
yourself is it going to click
yeah and this is the first time jerry
jones has put together a highly talented
team but something is keeping that team
from being as good as it can be and
frankly at some point you have to ask
whether or not that thing that is
keeping the team from being as good as
it can be is jerry jones and i don't
know that he would ever engage in that
type of an evaluation of himself because
he isn't going to fire himself as the gm
of the team but that may be one of the
reasons why this team is struggling
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports